hoje vou ensinar a fazer o ventilador do
local possibilita usar mesmo do gerador
elétrico
veja só o cabo usb do computador a
maioria dvd player coisa nos chapas
finas por um tempo mas você não tiver um
dvd player não há problemas podem usar e
que um dos indivíduos que querem
aprofundar avaliado ou você já não usa
que também dá até esta parte foi
bastante conexão juntou à mãe de um cabo
usb para carregar telemóveis tablets e
outros aparelhos do gênero caso usb
usado tinham fracos e teclado e não
funcionam podendo atenção muito baixa e
mais sucinto para fazer girar o motor
cortez dois filmes
o verde eo azul passarmos por qualquer
informação dos aparelhos
agora à noite longe de carné e
conectá-los um investimento que a
distância para conectar da autora minha
parte quando começa o rio branco
ela é cobertura branca é importante
deixar aquela distância não dar
problemas no futuro na incorporação de
um tour pela escola
imagino que vocês vão ter acesso à carga
no link inscrição você destinados para a
página do facebook e lá tem imagens em
grande e pra vocês podem contar quando a
fim de fazer então podem sim pra mim é
mais fácil ou então podem sempre ir ao
verdão irá imagem delas mais bonitas uma
capa de um dever e que é muito viável e
fica mais moderado quando é aquecida
inter foi preciso sair mais a imagem vai
testar tanto fazer que corre é que esse
tipo a semelhança do olímpico olé
é fácil cortar coisas do um corta unis é
importante fazer este corte e ver mas
depois você conseguir ser as páginas
eles apenas uma parte central do
bondinho é mais um vídeo dos parques com
essa forma de explicar o quanto ele está
feliz
o calor ajuda a tornar o espetáculo mais
maleável e planta que está uma vela que
vocês podem usar o skype ou outra coisa
qualquer um pudesse manchar um pouco não
vou usar escutar pois queima e torcendo
na direção já agora vocês vão poder
expor dois lados e tem que ficar com uma
torção possível dos dois lados ou seja
espaço e vamos conquistar
o jogo era aberto melhor que ficou junto
ao santo andré pode sentar agora pode
até o final porque o sport o época
entrou por no ecrã do computador em
consiste em cortar uma tampa quase a mãe
com uma faca maior e outra mais pequena
e rica para que ele encaixa melhor
desta maneira ele vai usar dois
políticos de picolé fazer uma base forte
para trás do computador que vocês não
viram no início quando que dois podem
usar só o coritiba deu sem usar dois
fica mais forte e é uma coisa que eu vou
usar então vai ficar aí sim ser o seu
papel sinal você pode encher com cola
dele vai ficar mais pesado ficar mais tá
bom então não fala logo ela para que o
américa voltou lá agora e deixar um
outro problema
é só deixar as casas
esta partida deve ter cuidado e higiene
para quem por que passava creme dias no
ecrã etapa quem está do lado da imagem
deixada em 120 masculina mas pronto
vocês já estão gostando do voto secreto
agora acumular dois políticos locais
veja que fica logo partiu para cima e lá
que eu vou conectar consumidor ou por
elas como filhinha cole e ajustar a elas
se entrosar bem vindo a dar o melhor
já está até agora coletar do protocolo e
na tampa e jaqueline se deixar que elas
vêm sendo feito para não atrapalhar eles
fazem se torna se fácil conectar melhor
tá uó sabe que o início do evento ao
contrário é uma questão de honra por ter
qualidade podem ligar o computador ou
então esta parte do texto
outra coisa que não seja um novo acordo
a ficha e funciona também e já está até
takla
conversamos perguntei você precisa ter
capital e deixar os comentários que eu
escondo 22 20 e vocês podem degustar foi
tão claro e para você fizer mesmo vou
deixar minha filha lá na página do
facebook eu gosto de ver essas coisas e
propenso a isso é o próximo